now this is a story all about how will
smith's life got flip turned upside down
yes just like the prince of bel-air
smith's story has had some major twists
from rapper to slapper will smith is
never boring
you might be surprised to discover that
will smith's story actually doesn't
begin in film but in music performing as
dj jazzy jeff in the fresh prince smith
and his dj jeffrey townes were the first
ever recipients of a rap grammy for
1989's parents just don't understand the
duo picked up another trophy in 1991 for
summer time then came smith's solo music
career and men in black the song he
wrote for the movie earned him his third
grammy and in 1999 getting jiggy with it
scored smith grammy number four he's had
some nominations since then no small
feat but has put his music career on the
shelf to focus on acting for most people
four grammy wins and eight nominations
would be enough to retire for smith it
was a side project
will smith is no stranger to critical
bombs as his rotten tomato scores show
between wild wild west at 16 percent
bright at 27 and suicide squad at 26
these movies fall squarely into bomb
territory still it's hard to beat m
night shyamalan's 2013 sci-fi flop after
earth which received a rancid 12 on the
tomato meter ouch in this movie smith
plays a wounded father to a scared kid
played by his real-life son jaden set on
a hostile planet after a crash landing
it's hard to tell whether the acting
direction or screenplay was the worst
part of this film but for will the worst
part was almost certainly the backlash
against jaden who was just 14 at the
time smith told esquire that was a
valuable lesson for me a few years ago
with after earth that was the most
painful moment in my career
of course smith's rotten tomato numbers
aren't all bad men in black got 92
percent and king richard scored a 90.
after a successful run on the sitcom
fresh prince of bel air which ran for
six seasons from 1990 to 1996 smith got
the chance to prove he was more than a
rapper turned comedian by starring in
ali this 2001 biopic about legendary
boxer muhammad ali formerly known as
cassius clay follows ali's career from
the mid-60s to the mid-70s this was a
tumultuous period for the fighter during
which he won several iconic matches
while publicly commenting on hot-button
issues like the vietnam war and the
civil rights movement while ali didn't
break any box office records it was a
hit with critics demonstrated by this
rotten tomatoes critics consensus blurb
though perhaps no film could fully do
justice to the fascinating life and
personality of muhammad ali man's
direction and smith's performance
combined to pack a solid punch the role
also nabbed smith his first oscar
nomination for best actor in a leading
role it was proof that while he was
bankable as an action-comedy star he
could also hold his own with the best
when it came to drama
will smith was riding high at the end of
the 90s the fresh prince of bel air his
success in the music industry and his
leading man status in several
blockbusters had all turned him into a
household name but did you know he was
almost the star of another 90s franchise
maybe you've heard of it a little sci-fi
movie called the matrix
what is the matrix it is the world
that has been pulled over your eyes
that's right smith was almost neo but
the reason it didn't happen might
surprise you smith turned down the
matrix to star in wild wild west a
decision that seems a bit um misguided
in retrospect because while the matrix
is a beloved and thought-provoking
sci-fi gem wild wild west was a
forgettable bomb smith posted a youtube
video explaining what happened i did
turn down neo
in the matrix according to smith he was
a bit overconfident following the
success of independence day and probably
trusted his gut a little too much but he
isn't throwing any shade on the sci-fi
classic keanu was perfect lawrence
fishburne was perfect and as smith said
in the video it was all for the best i
probably would have messed the matrix up
i would have ruined it
will has always been a proud family man
including his kids and projects whenever
he can for example he starred with jaden
in a number of movies and while after
earth might have been a mistake the
pursuit of happiness certainly was not
in this 2006 movie smith stars as a
homeless man desperately trying to make
a better life for his son christopher
played by jaden according to rotten
tomatoes it was a critical favorite and
an excellent debut for jaden just eight
years old at the time will's on-screen
portrayal of a man who deeply loves and
wants the best for his son was clearly
genuine
the smiths seem to think the world is
clamoring for every detail of their
personal lives we ride together we die
together
bad marriage for life
but there's a fine line between open and
honest and really really awkward for
example in his memoir will goes into
excruciating detail about his sex life
with his wife jada pinkett smith saying
we had sex multiple times every day for
four straight months as far as i was
concerned there were only two
possibilities one i was going to satisfy
this woman sexually or two i was going
to die trying imagine being one of his
kids and reading that speaking of the
kids where do we even begin with red
table talk a facebook show in which jada
daughter willow and jada's mother adrian
banfield norris say things the public
really doesn't need to know geez this is
scary but it's real for example our
hosts discuss how willow learned about
sex after catching her parents in the
act and how um self-service has always
been a part of jada's life listen
transparency is cool but so is keeping
some things to yourself
while having famous parents certainly
gave smith's kids a big advantage this
doesn't mean jaden and willow aren't
talented in their own right and since
their success is also a win for will it
lands on the best category of our list
other than being a smith daughter willow
is most famous for her undeniably catchy
2010 single with my hair which peaked at
number 5 on the us pop charts as for
brother jayden he was featured on justin
bieber's 2010 song never say never which
peaked at number 8 on the billboard hot
100. never say never was the theme song
for the karate kid reboot with jackie
chan a film that jaden also starred in
and let's not forget that the pursuit of
happiness another movie he co-starred in
with his dad was a critical favorite
it's nice growing up rich to famous and
well-connected parents but fame's got a
darker side too and the smiths haven't
been immune to it buzzfeed had all the
details of a conversation smith had with
daughter willow who was touring europe
with justin bieber at age 10 to promote
her 2010 hit with my hair one day after
finishing her set and leaving the stage
willow said to will thank you daddy i'm
finished the ever professional smith
tried to convince his daughter to
complete her tour obligations to which
willow replied it doesn't matter to you
that i'm done daddy
it's a lot of work this question
affected will who realized his own
feelings had never been considered when
he was growing up he then realized he'd
been dropping similar baggage on his
daughter fortunately the encounter
changed his approach to parenting from
what he described as pushing and
prodding and cajoling people into the
vision that i had demanding that people
do the things i had envisioned for them
into something much different with smith
desiring to water and nourish and
nurture that seed to become what it
already is
now you might have realized that will
smith isn't in many billion dollar
blockbusters those seem to be reserved
for superhero movies these days and
smith's main attempt to get his foot in
that door resulted in suicide squad
hardly a badge of honor
oh not good
don't forget
we're the bad guys but that doesn't mean
he isn't bankable although only 2019's
aladdin made it to the one billion
dollar mark his cumulative box office
hall stretches far into the billions
business insider brought the receipts on
25 of the highest paid movie roles of
all time and will smith appears a few
times pulling in 40 million for king
richard and most impressively nabbing
the top spot with a 100 million paycheck
for his role as agent j in men in black
three
you know
yeah
we've already discussed the awkwardness
that is red table talk but the most
noteworthy incident by far had to be the
july 2020 episode when jada invited will
on the show to admit that the rumors
that she had cheated on him with rapper
august alcina were true she explained
that the affair happened because she and
will had been going through a rough
patch saying i just wanted to feel good
it had been so long since i felt good it
was really just a joy to just help heal
somebody even if you didn't watch the
bombshell episode you probably saw the
memes of will's face from the episode
where it looks like he's bursting at the
emotional seams even more embarrassing
while will referred to the incident as a
transgression that he's willing to look
past jada said i actually don't look at
it as a transgression at all
it's weird to even mention it in the
context of the now infamous slap that
preceded it by a few minutes but we do
need to note that will smith did take
away one of the top prizes at the 2022
academy awards best actor and it's not
like he didn't earn it smith received
massive acclaim for his portrayal of
richard williams the hard driving father
of tennis superstars venus and serena
williams venus and serena go shake up
this world on rotten tomatoes smith is
praised in the critic's consensus king
richard transcends sports biopic
formulas with refreshingly nuanced
storytelling and a towering performance
from will smith in the title role but
the slap overshadowed what should have
been a triumphant moment i want to
apologize to the academy i want to
apologize to all my fellow nominees art
imitates life i look like the crazy
father just like they said about richard
williams but love will make you do crazy
things you're gonna be the greatest of
all time he did get a standing ovation
when he was done but there would be
massive blowback to follow
the 2022 oscars should have been a slam
dunk for will but his best actor victory
was overshadowed by what occurred just
moments before in response to a joke
host chris rock made at jada pinkett's
expense a comment that touched on her
alopecia will stormed the stage and
slapped rock across the face any notion
that the incident was staged was put to
bed when smith shouted obscenities of
rock after returning to his seat it
immediately became one of the most
talked about moments in award season
history the fallout of the slap heard
around the world hit right after the
ceremony was over in an interview with
gail king
jim carrey said he was sickened by the
standing ovation smith received after
his oscar win smith did speak on
instagram the next day saying quote i
would like to publicly apologize to you
chris i was out of line and i was wrong
but as sincere as the apology may have
been consequences were inevitable the
bbc says that in april the academy of
motion picture arts and sciences elected
to ban smith for 10 years over the
incident while the new york post says
netflix and apple pulled out of a
bidding war for an upcoming will smith
biopic netflix has also pulled the plug
on a sequel to their 2017 hit film
bright which would have netted will
smith a hefty 30 million dollar payday
as you can see smith isn't just the king
of bel air he's also the king of the
career ups and downs will he make his
way back up to the top stay tuned to
find out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]